it's a conversation that I want to have
that I get to have and try to
communicate to that 12 year old kid just
like how to telescope this is years
before Google was invented nevertheless
if there was some you know kind of
melding of nanotechnology where you
could connect to the physical world from
the digital world of AI where it has
some imperative hello and welcome to a
very very special and exciting 100
000 subscriber Milestone episode of the
into the impossible podcast with yours
truly Dr Brian Keating didn't think I
would hit this Milestone so soon perhaps
I really started the channel in Earnest
back in the year 2020 that channel was
around for a few years before that
getting you know a couple subscribers a
year uh since 2017 2018. but it really
kicked it into full gear in 2020 and was
uh delighted to see the exponential
virality of the show continue to grow
the hockey stick fashion to which I have
become accustomed and inured but I don't
take it for granted it's really a
tremendous
value to me it causes me so much joy and
gratitude to you all so I'm excited to
keep making videos for you I have so
many cool ideas for solo episodes and
for a new guests coming up look deep
into the fall of this year 2023 and that
will hopefully take us to 150 000
subscribers before the end of the year
that would be quite phenomenal and we'll
do another q a BK q a at that Milestone
uh so stay tuned for that I couldn't do
any of this really without all of you so
incredibly blown away and super super
duper thankful and so I solicited
questions on Twitter on Instagram
especially on YouTube in the comments
section so just really again I implore
you to to take the opportunity to ask
questions there to follow me and
subscribe over there and all these
different venues most importantly on
YouTube but I'm so active on Instagram
and Twitter same handle Dr Brian Keating
with Dr Brian Keating and you can find
me there I kind of refused to do Twitter
on moral grounds of personal grounds
maybe I'm missing out on some really
important you know viewers that would
subscribe to this channel I don't know
be that as if they can't really complain
because this Milestone uh was really a
long time coming you know I it's joking
before I thought it would happen uh
maybe eventually before the heat death
of the universe but I actually kind of
feel given the amount of high quality
guests that I get on from 14 Nobel
prizes winners and three Pulitzer Prize
winners and four astronauts and five
billionaires and uh some people that are
very little known but equally impressive
that I think the channel deserves even
more subscribers and I was joking with
one of my friends that if I ever talked
about getting a million subscribers you
know I gave him permission to punch me
in the face and you know who you are out
there I'm not going to really talk about
numerical values just to say that I'd
like it to grow and we're already
growing we're at by the time you're
watching this we'll be close to 115 000
subscribers and it's not the number of
subscribers you know that you get to get
buried with like a pharaoh you know with
with his uh golden uh artifacts but it's
a way of you know kind of documenting
the quality of the channel too because
it's hard to get a hundred thousand
people you know that's that's bigger
than you know uh very many towns that
I've lived in in my life and bigger you
know it's twice as big as the university
that I teach at so it's it's really
quite gratifying to me to to think
there's a hundred thousand hundred and
fifteen thousand of you right as of now
but I do feel like we can take the
message of connecting a million Minds
together literally and through your help
we can do that I'll say more about that
later now I want to get on to the
questions so got hundreds of questions
can't answer them all I want to uh thank
you all and again you can ask me on
Twitter Dr Brian Keating YouTube Dr to
Brian Keating in the community section
or any of the comments sections I read
all the comments not really you know
reply to all of them I do try to read
them in on occasion you'll see a heart
down there so uh there and on Twitter Dr
Brian Keating you can ask me questions
so I did get one uh from uh Instagram
I'll go to that second but first I want
to start off with Tim Wilson on YouTube
who said I remember about a year ago
that I wished you this stat in other
words a hundred thousand congrats on 100
000. thank you Tim I'm very very
grateful to you and uh the cohort of
Brilliant Minds that listen and feedback
we do Live Events it's really just so
much fun I always joke you know when I'm
working in Chile or in some project at
the South Pole you know we have to deal
with people contractors and and you know
there's demands from the universities
and the bureaucrats and the lawyers and
stuff that those are people I have to
talk to but when I get to talk to you
all and talk to to my colleagues and
friends that come on the podcast or do a
solo episode that is with my favorite
guest which is me then I it's a
conversation that I want to have that I
get to have and I'm trying to kind of
adopt that mindset for everything I do
you know sometimes I catch myself saying
oh I have to teach you know now I have
to go teach have to go and you just say
it really quickly lately I told my wife
I'm starting to say I want to teach I
get to teach I'm honored I'm privileged
to teach I have more to say about that
later uh and and as you know my my
favorite cohort to teach are those that
you know are kind of taking the path
that I was on decades ago which are
young students either you know
graduating from high school about to be
college students college students
graduate students post-docs young
professors as well as just the
interested lay person you know my goal
is that I provide free you know
content that you can consume that uh is
really you know it's free to you but it
cost me time and money to do it but the
reason I do that is because you pay my
salary and you pay the salary of other
scientists around the world and the 100K
figure allows you know other people to
see that there is a value in what we're
doing so the subscriber count is
important and it does have influence on
Publishers you know I wanted a few years
ago to get ray dalio on the podcast
famous another billionaire um I'd love
to have he's a great thinker I've read
his books and he declined or his people
decline I don't have his email address
handy if you do out there Ray it's time
to come on at the time maybe I had 20
000 subscribers and as publicist
basically said uh you know thanks for
the request but channel is too small
it's not really worth his time and I I
didn't say how dare you live to regret
that no of course it makes total sense
and it's not the size of the audience
you know that really determines
everything nor is it the size of the
followers of the guests that determine
you know the quality I've had some
incredible interviews that have gotten
tens of thousands of views with people
that you know no one has ever heard of
in the general public you know people
know the Eric weinsteins or you know the
balaji's that I get on the podcast
um Ryan holiday you know all these
famous quote-unquote people Ben Shapiro
Jordan Peterson but uh but very few
people have heard of Neil Turok and yet
his episode has more than a quarter
million views Mark kaminkowski came on
these are little-known intellects
outside of a very very Niche Cadre
cohort of fellow astronomers or
physicists like myself but I bring them
to you and then I'm just delighted to
see the uh the response and so that's
sort of the mission that we're on when I
go back and look at Instagram I got a
couple questions over there one I want
to answer from my friends at Judaism
demystified they had me on their podcast
but they asked a question what was I
like as a young kid as a scientist was I
interested in science so yeah guys I was
interested in science I was always
interested in science I just never
thought you could do science as a career
I never thought it was possible to to
actually get you know the knowledge of a
scientist into my head and my body and
have those experiences and and learn
from these Minds I didn't think I was
qualified to to be one of them and that
feeling you know related to The Imposter
syndrome I guess is common one I deal
with that in my books and then with my
guests I try to bring them down to you
know an accessible reality so that a
young person you know 12 year old 13
year old in the same position I was
decades ago will see that this is not so
you know mystical that scientists are
human beings despite the stereotypes so
um I I think you know part of the
scientific mission is to cultivate uh an
aura of invincibility of perfection of
being above the scrutability of the
general public again I think that's
dangerous not just for you know kind of
scientists and science itself because
science is dependent on the funding of
people who aren't scientists most
there's way more people who aren't
scientists than fun scientists than
there are actual scientists so I think
it's imperative that if we don't give
back to the community and show what it's
like to be a scientist to teach to to
educate the public and what it what
we're really doing with their money it's
very perilous for the future of science
so I try to do that and try to
communicate to that 12 year old kid you
know who just like had a telescope this
is years before Google was invented this
is years you know before I'd really have
my first big telescope and and think
about going to college and think that I
could do something so impractical is
astronomy or physics you know because
it's really not immediately obvious to a
12 year old and even to an adult how
valuable physics might be as a career it
turns out it's extremely valuable the
skills that my students Garner are in
incredible demand because it really
spans the gamut from learning to code
and program all the way up to
understanding the deepest aspects of of
calculus and math mathematics and
theoretical physics to experimental
physics to circuits to Optics to
thermodynamics to engines to Rockets
everything is contained within physics
in the physical world even biology has a
role in physics and certainly chemistry
you know direct joked a long time ago
that his Dirac equation of the
relativistic form in the shortener
equation
described most of physics and all of
chemistry and then you know since
chemistry is the foundation of biology
and biochemistry so all the more so
physics is at the root of all these
subjects so it is it it seems sometimes
impertinent or irrelevant but actually
it is the foundation the operating
system on which all of the physical
Universe works so my job is to inspire
those people in the way that I was
inspired was by authors we didn't have
YouTube channel but we didn't have such
things so I relied on the OG original
you know our original influencers and
then those are authors and you have
audio books one of them as a kid it was
very uncommon at least so so for those
reasons I want to bring authors to the
minds and the eyeballs of young
listeners and all listeners too to
inspire them and to make them feel they
could get some good Roi return on their
investment in the scientific Endeavor
that I'm privileged to be a part okay
let's go to Twitter questions so the
first one comes from my friend Jeremy at
alien scientist he has a question with
it with an image why is there a
terahertz Gap in the electromagnetic
spectrum is there something special
about those freaks and wavelengths not
really freaky uh Jeremy there is uh
really nothing special there is no Gap
in the electromagnetic spectrum there
are band gaps in semiconductors that are
related in this in this Gap that you're
showing here there's a phonon polaron
gap those are usually due to the crystal
lattice structure there's no missing
band of frequencies where there are no
electromagnetic waves and the terahertz
frequency especially that's really not
that exotic that's what we call far
infrared we use it all the time we've
even measured photons from that earliest
moments of the Big Bang called The
Cosmic microwave background and uh no
problem with those there's no Gap that's
been observed thank you for the question
see moving on to a voytech grabby Edge
uh he asked how much does the known
universe weigh how much subatomic
particles can you squeeze together
before starting a chain reaction and
expanding how much force would be
required to control the Chain Reaction
explode right there's a couple there's
three questions here I'll just stick to
one of them we don't discuss what the
universe weighs weight is really a
byproduct of uh what we call Force
which manifests itself on Earth as a
product of the mass of all the particles
that make up a given object multiplied
by the acceleration due to gravity of
the entire Earth's Force squeezing in
and pulling in on those particles that
are on the scale the universe there's no
scale to put it on there's no constant
gravitational field to weigh it on
there's no Force being General net force
because I would prefer a direction in
space which we don't observe so I'll
take that question to mean something
else the mass of the universe so the
mass of the universe is actually equated
to an energy via Einstein's E equals MC
squared
and the total mass of the universe
appears to be
strangely paradoxically maybe not
Paradox but strangely it's equal to
What's called the critical density the
critical density is that density which
is required to create what's called a
flat universe a universe with no spatial
curvature a universe in which you shoot
out two initially parallel laser beams
and they will remain parallel forever
which is not the case if there were
spatial curvature to the universe
causing either them to diverge as they
bite in a in a positively curved
universe and a negatively curved
Universe like a saddle or converge as
they do in a positively curved Universe
like a sphere so there is evidence that
the Universe has what's called the
critical density the critical density
when converted to mass which then you
could convert to weight if you really
wanted to but that would only apply on
Earth so you can't think about putting
the the entire universe on scale that's
happens to be on the Earth's surface
that has no gravitational potential
deviation you hear a constant field it
doesn't exist so let's just talk about
the mass the average mass in the
universe per cubic meter is equivalent
to about five protons there are about
five Pro protons worth of energy in
every cubic meter of space a proton has
a mass energy equivalent to what's we
call about one giga electron volt one
billion electron volts so that's an
energy required to accelerate in an
electron to have a potential of 1
billion volts it's strange units but
remember energy is equivalent to mass
via E equals MC squared so you can
convert the electron volt Mass the five
protons to a mass or the electron volt
energy to a math and then you could say
how many electron volts there are so
it's about roughly 5 billion electron
volts per cubic meter of energy or five
protons work now seventy percent of that
is not in the form of matter at all 70
percent of that energy equivalent is in
the form of dark energy which we know
almost nothing about we have almost no
good theories about it we know that it
exists Einstein thought it existed
originally to keep the universe from
collapse saying he needed an expansive
anti-gravitational Force to counteract
the gravitational force of the matter
that he was made up of and so in the 19
teens he came up with the theory of
general relativity applied it to the
universe which to him was just the Milky
Way galaxy he didn't know there were
other galaxies until 1923 when Hubble
proved that and even after that he still
believed until 1929 when Hubble showed
him the universe was expanding Einstein
believed that the Universe was static so
my own joke you know it's too bad he
could have had a good career if he
didn't make that biggest blunder
repeatedly as he called him so that's
the mass energy of the universe most of
it's in the form of dark energy the
remaining 30 percent is mostly dark
matter again something we know a little
about maybe a little bit more than dark
energy we've never detected any form of
dark energy at least we've detected one
form of Dark Matter honest to goodness
dark matter and those are called
neutrinos neutrinos are massive they
have a mask very very tiny minuscule
Mass but they have a mask and we decide
their contribution to the cosmic energy
budget so they have mass energy and
they're not interacting with light
they're dark matter they're forth dark
and massive there's not enough of them
to account for the 30 percent of matter
that is comprising the rest of the
cosmic pie chart that is a conundrum
what is the dark matter made of what is
the ordinary matter made of now what's
so interesting is that if you look at
the so you know the cosmic pie chart you
know the composition of the universe so
the pie chart the cosmic energy budget
the elements that we're made up of
besides hydrogen helium in the water uh
oh we're not made of much helium but a
lot of hydrogen and a lot of the water
molecules in our body the heaviest
elements on the periodic table like
carbon nitrogen all the metals as
astronomers call them anything heavier
than hydrogen only makes up three one
hundredths of one percent of that cosmic
energy budget so that means you need
basically you know hundreds of volumes
multiplied by meters cubed before you
get one proton on I went honest to
goodness proton in the universe of the
type of protonic matter that we're made
up of there are hydrogen atoms nuclei
throughout the Universe and cosmic rays
and so the mass of the universe is
incredibly tilted towards the abundance
the preponderance being dark energy so
that answers your question thank you
very much let's go back to Twitter
Genesis described this is from Charlie
fry Genesis describes existence before
creation as tohu babohu can it be
describing what a black hole is Charlie
thank you I don't think so I don't think
it's describing anything physical I
think it is speaking in terms of a
metaphoric license the job the Creator
God undertook from Genesis 1 1 was to
separate things and the separation is
delineated in many different attributes
light from Darkness you know Earth from
Sky water from from matter day from
night as they say and then uh ultimately
he humans and animals and then amongst
the humans males and females says God
created them male and female so they
told is actually the only example where
it's combining something that is are
synonymous with each other chaos and uh
disorder or you know uh everything was
was uh basically disordered and chaotic
those are not you know antonyms those
are not divisions it's almost as if
there's an amalgam of everything now if
creation can be thought of as a in
astronomical terms it would seem to me
to be more akin to a white hole
producing matter not absorbing or or
somehow constraining and causing matter
to enter into an event or as sort of an
event horizon in Reverse so I don't
think so okay A friend
um who has a very very Winsome name
Prometheus warp X
softball question for my fellow
space-time traveler Kenneth spacecraft
equipped with sufficient warp drive
technology successfully enter and leave
a black holes Event Horizon fully intact
the answer is we don't know but most
likely not that's a tough one uh we have
no idea some of these things are not
even definitively interact you can't you
know be sure that there isn't is such
thing as a warp drive and that could you
enter even into a black hole classically
no you could never enter and leave it so
Prometheus thank you so much Jamie Brown
killer clown 37 Define existence well
existence is an incredibly you know
obvious thing uh on one hand but a very
very difficult thing it's a lot like
Consciousness when they talk to people
about Consciousness they say you know
basically we can't know what your
experience of Consciousness is and
furthermore we can't even understand
what our existence of Consciousness
experience of Consciousness is because
it varies from time to time time and as
guest in the show Donald Hoffman has
suggested it's an evolutionary coping
mechanism anyway so even our
Consciousness is subjective let alone
your Consciousness and I feel the same
way about existence oh it's sort of like
the the Supreme Court in the 50s defined
pornography you know it when you see it
but the fact that things can come into
and out of existence that matter is not
conserved in the universe only energy
these are extremely interesting things
to consider does a proton exist if it
can fluctuate into and out of existence
or an electrum Andrew McKenzie asks we
just State something
self-organizing plasma and the seeming
intelligence associated with I have no
idea what that means thank you for
asking uh Adam's handle is uh UFO
curious suggests I have anglian
scientist Jeremy Reese on the podcast I
have kind of pivoted away from direct
you know discussions of the alien um uh
kind of UFOs as actual extraterrestrial
intelligence I do have tentatively
scheduled a conversation with Professor
David spurgle uh who is leading NASA's
UAP study I know that makes some of you
incredibly uncomfortable that NASA is
commissioned the study but these are the
most formal scientists in the world and
according to astronomers
astrophysicists uh biologist
and so forth these are people with
mathematics backgrounds physics
backgrounds David spurgle is the
president on the Simons Foundation
doesn't work for the government it's a
totally independent panel we'll see
where that goes I'll continue to have on
people like Bobby Loeb and others that
are doing stuff similar to me which is
to try to acquire data and make the data
and their interpretation available to
the public 1001 Nights ask when will I
have Peter thielon okay so I've met
Peter Thiel a couple times six months
ago a year ago he stopped he had a a
meeting was attending a meeting that I
was at Europe and uh it was quite
delightful able to talk to him and learn
from him and and so forth and I asked
him to come on the podcast and he said
he would
um if he checked the news he's had been
having uh some controversies as the
British might say so I certainly don't
think it's on the horizon anytime soon
but he has a promise to do it we uh we
get along I think he's very interesting
he's extremely interested in philosophy
and physics astronomy and uh and
fundamental questions big questions of
existence and I hope that I hope to have
him on to discuss this uh when when
various things in his personal life get
resolved okay so I've got a couple more
here someone asked uh Des oxic what
happens here 80 000 q a was that a
patreon exclusive or something no it's I
don't know it's on the channel we look
back it's probably about six months ago
suppose God exists he goes on to ask
suppose God exists outside of what we
know is the universe would there be a
current definitive size and shape of the
universe for him would this even be a
meaningful question think it's a
question it's hard to think about you
know how to answer it properly in terms
of God existing outside the universe is
it uh in terms of the composition of the
universe can have
incorporeal or non-physically embodied
characteristics uh in other words the
the curvature of the universe if it did
exist and actually we don't know for
sure it's exactly zero with no
uncertainty everything in science has
some uncertainty so it could be the
universe does have a curvature when that
curvature extends to you know extremely
large distance scale such that the
radius of curvature is many times the
observable universes extent so right now
the observable universe is about 12 to
15 billion light years in terms of
particles that could reach us with
information uh today but since the
universe has been expanding since the
last 13 billion 800 million years the
universe has an even bigger sort of
Event Horizon over which particles could
even reach us traveling at the speed of
light right and so the universe could be
curved in those scales and that
curvature would contribute to its
acceleration or its expansion curvature
has an energy therefore it is not
altogether
unmeaningless to make up a word as you
say and to ask this question it is
possible for incorporeal to say
non-physically embodied entity so not
mass and energy or dark matter or dark
energy but actually curvature can
manifest and alter the shape size and
expansion of the universe so that is a
very interesting question as far as
existing outside of it that's sort of
Beyond when I can really comprehend at
this moment Gaston peer asked the
question if after a double Stern garlic
experiment regular interpretations of
quantum mechanics don't offer receivable
visualization of quantized spin
shouldn't that motivate us to be more
open to Exotic theories like the
transactional interpretation of quantum
attacks I'm not familiar with the
transactional interpretation quantum
mechanics there are many interpretations
of economy accounts I find them again
semi-unsatisfying it's like eating food
that somebody already ate in the end you
could do as I think merman said you know
shut up and calculate that's more kind
of aligned with what I like to do as an
experimentalist look at predictions that
can be tested using technology rather
than interpretation of things I mean
they're already like much much more
basic things that we can't interpret
properly I'll give you an example in
electromagnetism the electromagnetic
field e or the B field is not directly
observable potential is not directly
observable and these are imaginary or
actually complex not so how can we
interpret a complex number we never
measure it and it's like the amplitude
of the of the Schrodinger equations wave
function we can't measure that directly
we can only measure it when it's
collapsed or when it when it has been
squared and we integrate and calculate
probabilities uh probability densities
and those are things that have values
because those are real numbers the
square the the complex conjugate times
the complex number itself is a real
number and you can measure real numbers
we don't have voltmeters that have you
know complex numbers associated with
them so uh so I kind of you know get
frustrated by talking about what's the
interpretation the meaning is really
what an interpretation of quantum
mechanics is now is the wave function
real can we actually understand those
are not a satisfying type of questions
to me because we can't even answer you
know simpler questions like the what is
the interpretation of the electric field
which is something you could make you
know with just uh with just some static
electricity not like you need some warp
drive as Prometheus warp X would have us
okay floor for Rebecca from the
Netherlands I think uh Florian asks okay
here goes if the grand unified theory
gut is one force that separates into
three is there a theory that does the
same including all fermions like if we
look at the combined Force as a line
that line has several Peaks where
certain particles have their lowest
energy states weird question question
mark it's not weird uh I think you're
saying it's hard for me to fully
appreciate exactly what you're saying
but I think the question is you know
implying that the grant a so-called gut
Grand unified theory does not include
all the fermions well some granule
there's many Gran unified theories it's
not like saying the theory of special
relativity there's one of those there
are many Grand unified theories none of
them have been accurately you know
demonstrated to make predictions uh that
can be tested there's some by by friend
of the show Lee smalllin and Eric
Weinstein uh that that do some types of
unification and you know unification is
the unification of the three strongest
forces not including gravity Eric and
others are trying to unify with gravity
String Theory attempts to do that as
well but there's no theory of that my
joke is that we always put the toe
Theory of Everything ahead of the gut
the grand unified theory but many
brilliant people including past guests
uh Sheldon glasha winner of the 1979
Nobel Prize they tried to come up with
this you know Grand unified theory
eventually and it just didn't work so
that we can't actually have a we don't
actually have a grand unified theory
that works the same way that the lecture
week Theory the unification of
electromagnetism the and the weak Force
has been manifesting we certainly don't
have a theory of everything manifest
okay a couple more from Twitter and then
this is called a person by the name of
Tim physics theory of incomplete
measurements full handle why would it
why would space time be continuous if no
measurement of space or time is well
it's quite possible we believe believe
that space for example is at least
either continuous or its discretization
skill is much smaller than any ruler
that we could ever possibly construct so
the same question would apply to that
question why is space-time more granular
than our current measurements of space
and time are capable of resolving well
with better technology we could measure
smaller and smaller space-time intervals
so I don't really see that as as too bad
of a question or too uh Stark of a
paradox but maybe a misinterpreter okay
a couple questions is a good one
Alexander krupps and Twitter again uh
what do you think about the far view
lunar telescope array does it sound
feasible to create
a 20 by 20 kilometer antenna Hedgehog
structure on the moon in the next couple
of decades so I've actually been working
with Google labs and they've constructed
an artificial intelligence robot which
will answer things in my same voice I
actually have a voice synthesizer so for
the 150k episode maybe I'll be able to
to actually you know
um just have your questions answer every
single question you could possibly and
ask so for now though I will look up the
far view lunar telescope because I don't
know uh what it is the farview lunar
telescope array is a proposed project
that aims to create a large telescope of
the Moon consisting of a large number of
small telescopes so it's an
interferometric telescope like the very
large array now that I've been to many
times in New Mexico or the alma Atacama
large millimeter array that I've also
been to many times nearby my Simon's
array and Simon's Observatory projects
these telescopes are small there's only
one meter in diameter according to my
Bard like assistant the Hedgehog refers
to telescope Arrangement pattern they
mounted on small spiky structures that
resemble Hedgehog whether that's
feasible to do that well the first thing
is is depends on the technology we're
just now going back to the Moon we've
been off the moon for for decades um
we're planning to go now in the next
couple of years first orbit the Moon
then land on the moon and potentially
one of my past guests Jessica Maier
could be the first woman to ever land on
the moon hoping for her to come on I
interviewed her when she was on the
space station in January of 2020 in
those uh a memorable kind of start to my
podcast and career to have a guest
floating above my head at 200 you know
90 kilometers above me and that was
really fun to get massive often that in
all seriousness so um so we don't know
so first she has to land there friends
have to land there uh it'll be a few
decades before we can do large scale you
know terraforming on the moon or lunar
forming on the moon or Selena forming on
the moon so I don't know uh how feasible
it is I don't know what their budget is
I love radio astronomy and I think it's
interesting but we can do a lot of cool
radio astronomy from the ground and it's
not at all clear depending on
wavelengths or so and so forth that the
moon would be a better place to do these
types some measurements so let's see
I've got more questions similar people
there okay I'll wrap that up from
Twitter there's a bunch of questions
from floor and from other people some
comments again thank you guys so much
for your Twitter questions let's go back
to YouTube on the YouTube so again
remember you can always subscribe to my
content on YouTube and ask questions in
the community section I love getting
questions over there Twitter Dr Brian
Keating uh Instagram and even Dr Brian
achieving I uh just surpassed the 30 000
follower Milestone on Twitter I love you
all let's go back and look at the
questions from YouTube okay cool cat
asks are you as concerned about the
introduction of advanced AGI as Sam
Harris Nick Bostrom or Elon Musk maybe
so uh let's look at these guys I've had
one of the three of these on the podcast
and I think Boston I haven't had Sam
Harris
um not entirely sure
that I want to have them on he is kind
of a he's a very brilliant guy and he's
very influential obviously and there's
certainly a lot we could speak about but
there is sort of an attitude or an error
of you know that it is just so far
beyond you know kind of the the
selection criteria for him to converse
with somebody seems to be so you know
astronomically out of proportion you
know he may be completely reluctant to
engage I mean he's disengaged from
Twitter which I'm you know I'm very much
uh supportive of I'm trying to limit my
Twitter use I think it can easily be
addictive I've got young kids at home I
I don't want them on they try to swipe
my face when I'm talking to them like
I'm an iPad so I salute that there is I
think very clearly you know the
machinations back and forth about Trump
and and how you know Hunter Biden's
laptop could have had you know
demonstrated that uh you know he's a
murderer or something it was just
incredible
um and that he just can't walk back this
this claim that he has and I listen to
interviews with him with got Galloway
who's another uh difficult uh character
to talk about because you know he's he's
also kind of you know said he would come
on the podcast but did not um and kind
of wasted a lot of my time you know
trying to set up a podcast and pitching
ideas for when he does come on in and
then he just kind of blew it off and
would still go on much much you know a
smaller less intelligent audience uh
podcast than mine including Sam Harris
as I'm not saying Sam Harris's audience
is less intelligent I'm sure many of you
are subscribers to say Amazon as well
but I listened to a podcast with them in
2020 on the middle of the election
season and just talking about how Trump
you know literally could could cause the
the immolation of the whole planet if he
were re-elected and and some of the
concepts that they were talking about in
that podcast Galloway who has a podcast
that I listen to as I say and uh musk
that's sorry musk Sam Harris it involved
you know these insane kind of claims or
at least they sounded insane to people
in 2020 that because of trump he could
cause you know a war to break out in uh
in Central Europe between uh you know
that Trump would be the reason that that
Putin could use nuclear missiles and
that Trump could uh you know cause the
fan the Flames of racial you know hatred
and anti-Semitism and that Trump could
um be responsible for a breakdown in
relations with China and and that those
would pose an existential risk for this
planet and it's just insane because all
those things have come true and and
Trump hasn't been an author and even
after he was you know kicked out of
office and you could say what you like
about him I'm not like a huge fan and it
was never like a huge supporter of his
but if you look at it through an
objective lens which Sam is you know
he's supposed to be this guy who makes
sense literally that's a meaningless
podcast for him not to see this huge
Lacuna and his understanding and
prediction and not to issue a Maya culpa
about that yeah I was wrong you know
Trump is not orange Hitler he did not
cause the devastation and and to say
that well he didn't do it during his
first four years so and that shouldn't
give any Bayesian uh Credence to the
notion that he might also not cause it
in a second term but not at all
according to Sam Harris and and Scott
Galloway Trump would be responsible for
Wars in Europe and increasing hostility
with Iran and with which China it's just
a mesmerizing conversation to look back
on with the benefit of of hindsight and
to hear them speculating about the the
hatred and and that the need that that
Joe Biden will cause the the community
to be radically you know uh not
polarized the way it's just it's just
astounding the guy has no self-awareness
for this one he may be brilliant in a
variety of different capacities and I do
quote him from time to time always with
attribution that's a that's a must so
that's my little rant about Sam Harris
and Scott gallowing well these these
people seem to be obsessed with Trump
and uh I find it it it leads to a
diminution of their IQ by at least a
handful of points anyway
um Sam Harris has said that he thinks
artificial general intelligence could
easily cause the extinction of the human
race the extinction of the human race he
argues that AGI could become so vastly
intelligent that it would surpass human
intelligence and creativity and it to
decide that humans are a threat are not
worth keeping around so he's extremely
negative cool cap not Bostrom on the
other hand has a bit on the shell unlike
Galloway or Harris or musk again the
reason I want these people on is not so
that I can you know kind of rehash and
score up brownie points and get more
viewers on some episodes I found that
that doesn't really work
um you know in in the past I've had on
some huge guests and it led to huge
views I've had on some huge guests of
lit to no views I've had some some small
guests that led to huge views and some
small guests you know in terms of
followings this is completely random so
the reason that I want to guess on the
show is because I believe I have
something to offer then not not only
that they have something to offer me
because a lot of what these people have
said is available elsewhere in terms of
what they're interested in what would be
new is their interaction with me and
hopefully by the hundred plus thousand
people that tune in you know I'm the
most consistent guest on the show and so
hopefully you guys appreciate the way
that I do approach these things as is an
experimental scientist I'm not a
theoretical physicist you know with kind
of my head uh in the in the sky trying
to you know think of different ways that
I could possibly be right now I'm trying
to actually prove those theorists wrong
that's my job it's more to prove theory
is wrong by building telescopes that
Acquire data that subject theories to
the test like an assayer like what
Galileo wrote about a assayer is
somebody who has become to him with a
piece of what you think is gold which
you hope is gold and the assayer takes
that piece of gold and takes another
completely worthless Rock uh some other
thing called a touchstone takes a gold
and rubs the gold on the sub on the
touchdown and the way it rubs off can
either tell you that that piece of gold
is truly gold or if it's Fool's Gold so
what an experimentalist should do is do
the same thing the theorists come to us
I've got this new piece of gold the
universe began with inflation nope I go
out I take it rub it against the
Touchstone of the observational
cosmology and I reveal it to be dust or
something not exactly what it was
purported to do so that's why I want to
have people like like Nick fosterman who
I didn't have on really talked about his
theory of super intelligence or Elon
Musk who I haven't had on uh but musk is
a character in many ways first of all I
I would love to actually dive deep into
the psychology of him as a as a
physicist that might sound strange but
you know he's also a physicist and he
has lots of things to talk about when it
comes to philosophy and psychology he's
trained as a physicist studied physics
at UPenn and in Canada so I'd like he's
never been on with a with a physicist I
mean he tends to go on uh with people
like Lex Friedman and Joe Rogan and so
forth and that's great and this is right
and he has talked about aliens and so
forth but there are concrete questions
to ask him that nobody ever seems to do
which have to do with the practicality
and the actual legitimacy of Mars as a
destination versus other uh tools and
and
um and prospects for improving life on
Earth and and actually it seems as if
it's just like imperative to become
interplay monetary but no one ever asks
them why and then you know to the extent
that he does talk about things like AGI
as the question was asked from cool cat
um you know is it a risk he says it's a
risk greater than nuclear weapons he
says that funding of artificial
intelligence is done to ensure that
Humanity stays on the right path he's
called for a six-month delay in
artificial intelligence development at
least in the west you know it's just
being like okay uh Microsoft you know
Bing Bard beep and Bop and Boop shut
down your research and um I'm sure that
China and North Korea and uh you know
and Bella Russia and I'm sure all these
places are just going to stop and pause
as we Ponder whether or not our
artificial intelligence should go beyond
uh the path that it's going I think it's
a fantasy I think he is acquiring uh you
know gpus he's smart he's getting
processing power the one thing that he
really needs are energy sources he's
looked at energy you know SolarCity and
so forth he loves solar energy that's
great obviously very deeply invested
with SpaceX and launch vehicles but I
see very little uh near-term use case
for you know going to Mars yes it'll be
an interesting tourist Place destination
to go the Moon is much more practical in
every sense of the word it could have
autonomous vehicles that are piloting
you're not gonna have like people and
with joysticks you know cruising around
the moon landing our Olympus mods you're
going to have robots doing it and those
robots will be commanded by some onboard
HEI and then some IGI that's on Earth on
these vast Nvidia you know super
clusters that you know take up the size
of the gigafactory so that's impractical
that's 15 minute you know round trip and
on the on the on the best case scenario
to steer the ship away oh we just got
new data we analyzed The Landing site
it's going to be a uh it's going to be a
sandstorm like past guest on the show
Andy Weir depicts in the Marshall you
know uh whereas on the moon it's a
second it's one second like travel time
the Moon is you know visible basically
all the time you know Mars is incredibly
difficult for very many months of the
year to actually communicate with no one
ever asks them why that Mars is such an
imperative or really crushes him you
know just keep going okay so what do you
need what's going to happen to the
biology of the system of the human being
up there he says he wants to die on Mars
you know does he want to die on impact
like just getting there does he want to
live for decades there also as a father
you know she's got 10 kids you know they
all going to come with him you know or
as uh different mothers of those kids
you know from um what's your name Grimes
to the other ones you know he's gonna
pack up a little X and and uh you know
baby astronaut suit or or if he has more
kids which the probability is not
insignificant that elon's gonna have
even more kids you know past performance
is uh is somehow indicative of future
performance so anyway
um I I'm not as nervous about AGI I use
it it's incredible I I was just um I
tweeted at Lex my buddy Lex and you can
see my interview with him on YouTube
which is uh I think that's one of the
top 30 year of all of this podcast in
terms of views which is really
heartwarming to me and we've talked
about doing a part two and I think when
I you know when I have something Lex
will appreciate we'll do a part two some
of you like Anthony Munoz is suggesting
I bring Lex on the podcast he did say he
would come on the podcast uh two you
know a year ago when I was on his
podcast down in Austin uh we haven't
made it happen he's been on Andrew
huberman's podcast a couple times
Andrew's a friend on the internet so to
speak uh we follow each other on Twitter
we talk and DM each other I've asked him
to come on again not to say like what
makes a good morning routine Andrew like
let's talk about that no I want to talk
about the physics of photo you know
chemical reactions in the retina I want
to talk about what would be the impact
on on if there is an alien civilization
that we encounter would they have day
night cycle circadian rhythms would they
have Starlight adapted Behavior how
should astronomers best optimize for
visual Acuity in Optical and you know
not every astronomer is you know using
the telescope in fact most astronomers
are not using the telescope or the
Hubble or the web and they're using
their eyes now looking at things they're
looking for tiny differences in visual
fields and we only have a tight visual
fovea area of attention we can pay
attention to diurnal Cycles every single
thing that we know in the universe spins
so that means another planet will Spin
and if that spin is not coaligned it
will with its orbital tangent vector or
anthion it will then cause a precession
which will lead to seasonal behavior on
the exoplanet could that be done and uh
art astrology asks has anyone in biology
or chronobiology ever done a comparative
analysis between the 20 amino acids and
the 20 days of the Mayas Mayan calendar
by sequence and function absolutely not
have no idea what that means well now
we're way out of the picture here but
frontal biology is something that Andrew
huberman who is one of the guests that
Alexis had on and Max has been on his
show it's all a big way of saying I'm
hoping to actually sit down and talk to
these people including Elon as an
experimental physicist and I think that
brings that's the reason why so many
people are interested in my video with
flex or with Jordan Peterson they've
never heard an experimental that they've
heard Michio Kaku go on Lex and talk
about you know the mind of God traveling
as an AI Avatar you know at the speed of
light uploaded to the universal Cloud
compute all this you know quite frankly
nonsensory sounding things nonsensical
sounding things and I like Michio I've
spent a lot of time with him in person
in the last couple years then on his
podcast he's been on mine but there's a
lot of hoopla there's a lot of hype
there's enough hype and science as it is
you know it's one of my prances that we
we have this Academia media hype cycle
where you know some to me you know up
some professors working in her lab and
she discovers something and then she
immediately thinks it would be nice to
get tenure and it'll be nice for my
graduate student to get a postdoc and it
would be nice if I got you know an NSF
Grant or an NIH Grant before I turned 50
you know it's almost the average age for
fnih grass at 41. for your first NIH so
you know there's some pressure that oh
well maybe I should promote This
research and I'll just stick to my field
maybe I'll claim that there is a
discovery of the inflationary origin of
the universe and maybe that'll be good
for me to get tenure become a full
Professor forget you know get a job
offer from an Ivy League school and stop
working at a public I'm just making all
this up but I want to make it real I'm
no better than anybody else but I'm also
no worse and when we get this temptation
for all sorts of accolades honors Awards
prizes funding with research attention
sabbatical credits you know it's a
committees assignments you know Dean
ships Provost it's a huge gain I can
athenia is a game and you have to play
it smart so actually I'm on LinkedIn
lately we've all play I used to think
LinkedIn was like you know you're
combining you know the desperation for
friends of uh Facebook uh with the
desperation for a job you know that is
LinkedIn uh but I've actually come
around uh Christina it's a very uh play
it's a great place for some people out
there you know uh I don't prefer to
associate with apparently there's a lot
of vaccine denial and there's a lot of
climate change denial and whatever what
I've seen of it is is really phenomenal
I get to talk to you know 15 000
graduate students undergraduate Pitts
postdocs and that's my key audience I
always say like the reason I give away
meteorites to you if you have a DOT edu
email address is because I want to play
a role in your education I want to be an
informal Mentor or educator for you do
you have time to answer all these emails
and so forth but also the content that I
put out and the people I connect you to
it's better than a hundred horror boots
you know it's I've been to these places
I have ivy league degrees I've been at
Caltech I know that the community of
people that I've put together with your
health because you guys give me this
massive quality and quantity that I can
throw in front of a publicist and say
look do you want to talk to the 100 you
know 20 000 most brilliant young minds
in in the world and older Minds males
and females every continent including
Antarctica and they'll say hell yeah
because they're not stupid they want to
get attention books are never going to
stop it's like the nail but the mail
never stops and your email never stops
you're getting a slack message right now
you better answer it but what we can do
is take advantage of that we'd want to
have more and more conversations with
the brightest Minds in the universe to
make a free University you can attend it
in your pajamas taught by the best
intellects in the world not just me I
think I'm okay but but you're gonna
learn from the greatest intellectual
world and the Project's going to expand
because we're going to bring in people
like Galileo like Feynman like Einstein
I'm in the process now of working with
somebody that I met on LinkedIn not
going back to LinkedIn and that person
and I are going to work on taking the
first starting by the acquisition that I
have of the you know 150 000 word
Dialogue on two World Systems by Galileo
so imagine putting Galileo into a
chatbot and putting that chat bot into
the world so that you can be taught by
Galileo there's nothing that you could
ask me
um that uh that was known at the time
okay so you can't ask Galileo that you
know what are the most uh novel ways to
sequence DNA but you can ask them
anything about mechanics about
philosophy about uh even things like uh
you know the existence of planets
outside of the Earth with life on them
and you can do that because he's got
these words digitized we can put them
into a chat bot and then we can actually
have his voice we can do in his voice
and we can't even have a visual Avatar
and I'm hoping to make that basically
free to to all of them so I'm excited
about
AI AGI I see it right now as a
competition between people that know how
to use it people that are terrified and
never use it and then the people that
are hyping it up so much like literally
every day I find about 10 new just like
incredible mind-blowing things I can do
with it thanks to people on Twitter I'm
LinkedIn should we go again and it's not
you know you can imagine that I won't
have to set foot in the studio leverage
they'll just take my face I'll write a
script with the help of you know some AI
stuff that's interesting about my
research maybe and then I'll have a
digital voice I'm not going to do that I
don't plan to do that because I think
you guys crave authenticity as do I I
don't want to listen to some you know
like deep fake of Byron Keating uh it
would be kind of cool to get out of you
know when Mike ever have your kid just
tell you a story don't know when it's
gonna end and you're praying you know
they're not going to be at ending that
you know kind of long story that's just
really involved about Minecraft and then
they're not just gonna end with like
well what do you think I should do I was
thinking about like you know chat GPT oh
so I'm really excited about that and how
to use it it's overwhelming how much
inbound information there is about and
it's very difficult to kind of separate
the wheat from the chat okay cool cat I
guess again as Rogan would be a good
guest yes I agree again I don't want to
go on Joe Rogan for my benefit like
somebody you know somebody asked me well
like now you've been on Lex Friedman Ben
Shapiro multiple times Jordan Peterson
you know who else is left Joe Rogan you
need to go on your room and somebody
actually asked them I didn't put in this
kind of one page of questions you know
like really talking about why I should
go on Rogan and so it's flattering again
you know he's had on a million no I
won't say that he's had on like five or
six theoretical physicists on
mathematicians there
call himself a physicist history
uh but he who comes off a mathematician
but he talks about physics all the time
let's be on uh Michio Kaku Brian Greene
Brian Cox Brian yazanana uh is this guy
um Michio Kaku multiple times and uh
Sean Carroll Lawrence Krauss these are
all have one thing in common all
theoretical physicists nothing wrong
with them so my best friends are
theoretical physicists but uh but as the
saying goes you know theoretical
physicist only has to be right once in
their life to have a legendary career
and some people have legendary careers
and have never made a prediction that
could be tested Ed win just to take a
side detour of someone who won't come on
the podcast and I don't even know if I
have them on the podcast quite frankly
because he has such a boring views about
Israel he sold what's called
anti-zionist that he really doesn't
almost seems like he doesn't believe
that Israel has a right to exist let
alone as a Jewish homeland and he seems
to only have that you know occupation
for it and I find that just almost
impossible to take just as if like
somebody came on the podcast and was
like I hate Italian Italy Italy should
not exist Italy should be given over to
you know some country that historically
has tried to destroy Italy and um and
there should be no two-state solution or
if there is it should be dominated by by
the anti-italians I don't want to talk
to such a person like that Israel has
plenty of flaws one of the great things
about it though is that they have open
and honest conversations or Arabs in the
Parliament and the knesset in the
military
you don't find that in uh in countries
you know it's not like uh you know
Germany in the 1930s had a lot of Jews
in the in the military or in the
government you know or South Africa then
a lot of blacks in the uh in their world
schickening of her pilot Bureau whatever
it was called or the Soviet Union they
didn't have a lot of their enemy those
are true apartheid States and and yes
you can agree and actually you know the
most uh kind of uh people that are most
of the vehemently anti-israel or Jews
and that wins a Jew of course but that
doesn't give you any special right
um to to he has some special knowledge
that you as a Christian might not have
so I find it very difficult to talk to
but let me just put that aside he won
the fields medal uh and so it's
incredible that he did that as a
physicist you know it's kind of kind of
crazy that that he's able to do it a lot
of what he did involve you know things
related to churn Simons and topological
um Estates of matter and the field
Theory a unified field Theory but none
of that's been had any connection to it
to technology to observations it would
be true if String Theory could somehow
be tested and maybe that's just a matter
of a future but um but for someone like
Joe Rogan to speak only to theorists and
and really listen to them as they wax
rhapsodically above you know as I said
Michio kaku's appearance on there it's
you know it's a little difficult to
listen to even you know Roger Penrose
again you know when he starts talking uh
from a you know an extremely esoteric
view way of describing the base layer of
physical reality Eric has this challenge
too many of you respond to the videos
like I have no idea what he said it's
word solid that's he can he can only
take something that's really complex and
make it more complex Eric is actually
you know brilliant
um uh as as it surmise but uh but in
terms of explaining base layer things an
experimentalist has to understand Theory
at least at the level of being able to
design an experiment to test that theory
and again our job is not to prove Eric
Wright or Eddie getting lights prove
them wrong and prove everybody wrong
except for one person who may be one of
you out there listening you with your
dot edu email addresses I think that's
really cool another guest that I had on
is being mentioned by Michael Smith
Freeman Dyson he was my first guest you
know the first real guest of this
podcast was Freeman Dice and then he
sadly died uh the very beginning of
Coven in March of 2020. so I got just a
tremendous out of mouth out of him
intellectually and just his spirit is
just so warm so loving such a delightful
impish you know uh person I miss him
terribly and I really feel honored that
he was Metro's cast and that could never
be taken away from him April then Ryan
we're in she's asking Elon why did you
sabotage your financial security by
buying Twitter so maybe it's a question
for me to ask Elon I think I could do
that as I say in a different way I think
I asked him you know when we talk about
what is the the vision of a Twitter and
I'd run different scenarios by him that
have a basis in physical reality in
other words how do you envision this the
the the payment of Twitter's predicate
almost entirely on the financial success
of Tesla and SpaceX in spacex's publicly
traded company but Tesla has is kind of
a proxy for spacing so you know how
these two things intersect with one how
does Twitter you know put your dreams as
you profess of going to Mars and dying
on Mars does this not impact though I
mean could you use another 44 billion
dollars and yes and he he obviously
committed to to free speech people like
Scott Galloway you know just can't stand
him and and they express their division
above him and his mismanagement of
Twitter on Twitter and he's obviously
like addicted to Twitter as he admits
and I always you know what to joke when
people like that and think you should
eventually charge rent Scott you know
because he's like in your brain 24 7.
Scott's got two podcasts on listen to
both in the one with Cara Swisher same
thing it's non-stop why Elon is the
worst person in the world why he you
know contributed to you know gays being
targeted and and uh you know as rhetoric
is is physically dangerous it's just
really incredible and there is no
connection between buying Twitter and
reaching Mars I think would be naive so
I would like to talk about that
obviously talk about ways that Twitter
could be used if it became part of the
interplanetary operating system then I
could see ways to do that that it would
need the massive upgrades right now I
cannot post this video on Twitter and
so-called monetize it and you can become
a subscriber to me on Twitter and I will
post off and I subscribe to Elon and
lacks and a few others on Twitter we pay
some number of dollars per month it's
kind of um mind-numbingly boring for me
to do that to manage I mean I very much
appreciate everybody on patreon who
supports me with a tremendous amount of
money on patreon and on YouTube via the
membership Vector I get paid a decent
amount of money from it probably about a
thousand dollars a month from all my
patreon supporters my Twitter supporters
my YouTube supporters and people that
send super things and so
um and I never take that for granted
that is incredibly generous and lovely I
just I don't have the time to use like
extra special content I'm too busy with
my only fans okay guys I cannot take the
time away from homely fans to dedicate
no um uh it's it's it's hard enough
making content as it is yeah I've got uh
two pretty serious other side hustles
then audio podcasts and I also am a
professor and uh you know trying to
reconcile all those together is is quite
difficult to then hand tailor content to
each of them so I will on occasion
express my gratitude and these kinds of
conversations but also I'll explain I do
send out special you know um subscriber
or patreon or YouTube member only gifts
like I gave away copies of audio books
I'm gonna go play physical books as well
um and digital books Kindle books of
some of my favorite books stay tuned for
that I'm doing that I also send
meteorites I've sent that over 2 000
meteorites to people around the world
they've listened to my podcast on other
people's podcasts and signed up for my
mailing list at buyingkeen.com list
again yeah email you automatically get
one of these Denise if you're in the US
it's kind of hard to send stuff out over
the international nail but speaking of
international I was recently on a
channel run by a guy who calls himself
Canadian prepper and it's a fun Channel
I've been watching this channel for
eight nine years now he's grown from
zero syllabus to over a million and he
runs a whole preparedness Channel where
he talks about a surprise tribalism and
and how to make strong kids and how to
line a fire in the woods and how to kill
a bear with your bare hands if he's just
an incredible guy but he also goes and
does a deep dive almost every night
about the politics of what he calls the
shizzy hitting the fizzy shtf or Tio
tawaki the end of the world we know it
and how to prepare for it because a
prepared mindset is one that wants to
live in the future and maybe I'll
describe it because what else do I have
to do right now I'm just enjoying a cozy
Farm maybe I'm gonna I'm gonna get the
stamina it's very cold in San Diego so I
made a fire here at the house at the
mountainead laboratory she found the
QWERTY Studio my Paws I'll be right back
from the light to fire Mickey Club they
are cool and we're back the fire is
roaring Can you feel it good thought in
San Diego in May on May the 4th be with
you I'm gonna need a Warren fire to keep
myself warm but it helps me feel cozy
that cheers me up Razzles this cup
courtesy of my Army brother Chad serving
his country protecting us Landon sea
kind of space 19
map my friend Canadian prepared beans so
I got in touch with him through a series
of well actually just one very snarky
comment on one of his videos where he
was talking about this so-called Bureau
bulletin of the atomic scientists which
is an organization that used to be
incredibly important and revered and
listened to even
Einstein was a member I believe this was
Oppenheimer that was back in its Glory
Days in the Cold War when its Mission
must prevent Atomic Holocaust from being
visited on Earth especially during the
Trump Administration they went deranged
as well and at one point I believe they
their job is to set the Doomsday Clock
so they set the Doomsday Clock to a very
very a close amount of time very very
minimal amount of time left and you look
this up they never move it backwards I
don't think they've ever like moved it
from yeah it's gone from 20 minutes to
midnight now it's like 30 seconds
January 24th of this year they released
that the Doomsday clunk had been moved
to 90 seconds to midnight now they had
done many many times back in uh 2017.
this is uh five days after the Trump
inauguration so that time they moved it
to from three minutes to destruction to
a mere 2.5 in other words just him
getting inaugurated was the reason the
ascent of Donald Trump never before as
the Bolton decided to advance the clock
largely because of the statements of a
single person of Mr Trump's statements
and actions have been unsettling I'm
sure that you know if Hillary have been
elected or you know abiding forever you
know they would they would have also
moved it because uh the events that
played out actually at the same time now
this has to go to my friend and uh
upcoming guest maybe by the time you see
this Hillary I've been a guest he's been
a guest in the past Lawrence Krauss of
Arizona State University at least he was
back then he was the theoretical
physicist and he was a chair of the
board of atomic sign bulletin of atomic
site and at the time he said that they
want to send a cautionary mess of six
days into an Administration that the
group says shows a glowing growing
disregard for scientific expertise uh so
it's incredibly political and maybe one
of my many flaws is that I never push
back on the crazy kind of out of
complete left field stuff that Myron
says we'll be doing an event Together
live in San Diego later this year I hope
Health stay tuned for that you'll find
out more if you join my newsletter at
briick.com list some of my first Live
Events
um for the podcast I'll be doing at
least two of them in San Diego stay
tuned for those anyway Lawrence you know
is kind of radically anti-trump and yet
he's found himself in some situations
not not like Trump accusations of of uh
you know sexual harassment that he
claims are baseless and let's put out
statements about that you know Trump
famously cleaning to grab you know women
in the you know where because they like
it when you're famous it's reprehensible
things that you know I wouldn't say
certainly to say that because of someone
like that that the world is as you know
essentially as close as ever to nuclear
Holocaust and I believe they moved it
again during Trump after you know that
was six days after he was elected you
know so all I think our publicity uh
stunts in many ways then I think they
moved it to uh yeah so then they they
moved it again in the year year about
2020 again this is you know the year of
covid right they moved in not because of
covid and Dooms data could result but
because of Trump's increasingly you know
irrational behave they moved it to a hot
9 a hundred seconds so they they went so
Trump came into office 2017 they moved
it 2018 a two minute to two minutes they
would have had two and a half minutes
from three minutes because he was
inaugurated then in 2018 for reasons
they don't really respond they moved it
30 seconds ahead then they did it again
in 2019 and then they moved it from 120
seconds to 120 SEC it's just ins it's
just a silly pointless thing that nobody
really thinks about because I'm so
publicized so what does this have to do
with Canadian preparedness well Canadian
prepper you know is kind of using that
information to bolster the case that you
know we're on a hair trigger and and
they moved it even closer to midnight
you know last last couple of months ago
and that was because of the uh the war
in the Ukraine which they completely
forgot to mention was caused during the
Biden Administration and many many
people have uh criticized Biden for his
role I'm encouraging it just recently
there was a drone attack but the
Russians said it was caused and
participation and an agreement by the
United States government they're sending
tremendous amounts of you know first it
was getting they're not going to send
anything then they're going to send
money now they're going to send missiles
then they're going to send tanks now
they're going to send an F-16 uh then
they're never going to send people now
there's people in Bella you know it's
just incredible how much more it's
Amplified that one conflict which is the
most serious conflict in my lifetime
since the Bas is probably uh you know
founded the bulletin to actually you
know bring us close to nuclear Holocaust
and Trump's nowhere to be found right so
anyway like them or hate them my friend
Nate Canadian preparing he put this
video out features this bulletin
seriously and I just commented in the
comments section no serious scientist
listens to the bulletin of atomic
scientists anymore let's completely
politicized and they're suffering from
Trump deranged in central like Manny in
Academia by the way I remember when I uh
came into my office to meet for lunch
with a colleague in the literature
department on November or what was it
10th of uh 2016 the day after he got
elected and I had coffee with her and
she was complaining that some of her
colleagues had betrayed you know uh the
human race and and certainly you know
she thought that they were the vote was
cast in a reprehensible fashion and I
said wait a second me to my colleague
whose name I will ravia but I said
you're kidding me like somebody in the
literature Department voted for you know
this is the most left-wing one of the
most leveling departments on our campus
and I've got many friends over there
and she said I said one of their
colleagues voted for Trump though no no
no no no they voted from Ernie they
threw their vote away they should have
been forever
all right I was like well I don't think
I really made a difference in California
anyway he posted this thing I kind of
snarked at him then he wrote me an email
and found my email address and was like
I don't know if you're being a jerk or
not but you're condescending comment uh
but you know when the real YouTube
channel like his with a million
subscribers
um I've watched since you know 2014 or
whatever when we present things to the
public it has to be done in a way that
has legitimate sources that could be
these back checked are confirmed by the
by the general public and it can't be
just for physicists like you that said I
checked out your channel and you've had
incredible guests and you do incredible
videos I'd love to have you on my show
to talk about threats of of you know
what an alternative to that bulletin of
the atomic scientist that's not
political which I think would be
incredibly valuable by the way anyway we
ended up having a two-hour conversation
earlier this week and that should air
pretty soon if it has ready I'll put a
link to it on my community Tab and add
his channel to my channel list of other
channels and uh you should find it
because I do believe that people should
be prepared we talked about a great deal
of things he's very philosophically
inclined and he has children like me and
we talked about how to raise them and
have a preparedness mindset to be
resilient in the face of potential for
at least the world looking very
different in the next 10 years than it
has in the last 10 years I think there's
no doubt about it and he's one of the
best in the business at kind of bringing
news and attention to your mind and he
pushes back on people it wasn't just
this you know kind of softball interview
the way that you know some people have
accused me of doing or maybe no I was
Alex you know nobody pushed back on
Brian or whoever so I learned a lot from
the interview I think he will see okay
uh let's get back to the roster of
questions I got a few more minutes
before I have my own office hours
um so here's a big one Rogan is not a
scientist astrology
art strollers uh correct he's in The
Scientist by talking to an experimental
physicist would be great for Henton to
learn about the practicalities of what
real physics is meant to do which is not
to think and talk about you know these
esoteric theories of wormholes and black
holes and you know warp drives and
everything those are fun to think about
but it's more fun to live in reality to
describe what we know and what we know
we don't know and prepare for those
kinds of mensualities because we're only
going to live for a few more years any
of us uh there's any Prospect for us
living beyond the lifespan of a tortoise
so let's make the most of it and to my
mind it's it's to you know kind of
falsify and invalidate as many theories
and so forth as we can in the future and
so yes we're going on Rogan's show I
think would be hopefully good for him I
don't mean that arrogant sound arrogant
conscious thing to give them different
perspectives never he said 10 different
people from a pure theoretical bed known
to an experimental bet then to talk
about the possibilities of detecting you
know aliens because you know to
um the threats of of uh artificial
intelligence to you know from an
experimentalist point of view where
these things are resource constraints
not like chat GPT is going to plug into
my fireplace and you know turn it into a
steam gas generator and power itself so
what are the physical limitations what
are the astronomical considerations uh
and to you know confront somebody who is
not just going to pitch in my own book I
don't have to sell my books you know
I've got a lavish lifestyle because of
that no uh but what I do feel is it's
important to to bring a perspective of
the kind of brass tax and reality so
some of these shows uh and I try to do
that one of the guests in other people's
shows as well and people seem to like it
uh the Jordan Peterson episode some
people are saying Sebastian episode that
he's done and certainly the best episode
I've ever done
um so I'm really gratified to hearing
those kinds of conflicts next uh get
Stephen wolf from on the show I've had
him on the show twice uh overturned this
is the thank you I'll I'll have him back
again
um he didn't you know kind of really
seem to enjoy the conversation with Eric
Weinstein so I think I would do another
solo episode with him again I've done
two episodes with him he's got some
really interesting takes on on
artificial intelligence and he's
interesting because he emails me all the
time Stephen lose my email buddy no no I
I love hearing from League like
sometimes emails and it's like hi Brian
I'd love to talk to you and uh or you
might be interested in this he doesn't
have enough to talk to us I'm sure you'd
be interested in this it might even make
me you know want to come back on the
show again soon wink wink and then I'm
like great Steven I read the article you
know from your blog I saw your interview
and my friend kerchief hungles episode
shout out to Kurt love you made him he
did such phenomenal work it was really
an unsung hero of this game and I
wouldn't have the number of subscribers
and fans that I have without him so
thank you Kurt but anyway uh so Stephen
will write me and then I'll write him
back a house tomorrow night in cricket
so Stephen if you're out there come back
on the Pod uh don't keep now making me
uh beg you to come out okay a busted
boat as an incredible question what is
the biggest threat to humanity that is
not nuclear war global warming or
artificial intelligence thank you so
much so I hear a lot about these other
ones so there are many different things
that aren't uh related at all to to
these things uh global warming Etc uh a
global Extinction events these are
things that you know just kind of
blindly you know kind of whistle past
the graveyard about but there are many
of them and I think you know just a
handful I can name in real time
asteroids super volcanoes another
pandemic but even the pandemic of condos
uh the worst kind in my mind though it
shall get to at the end is a pandemic uh
lack of faith or confidence Pam Beth
hello describe what I need in a bit uh
so what could an asteroid fast Reds
could wipe out tons of uh of life forms
on Earth as it did 60 million years ago
with dinosaurs that then set the stage
for small mammals rats rodents other of
my colleagues just kidding guys just
kidding no rats and AIDS rats desert
this [__] you guys don't know I'm just
kidding
um so when I uh think about asteroids I
always have to point out I give away
fragments of an asteroid that's what the
meteorite is uh if you have a edu email
address brykeen.com globally though what
could happen it would induce what we
think is a sort of a global winter like
a nuclear winter but caused by
artificial mean our natural means not by
man-made uh moved here
um uh detonation of a of a uh sort that
Carl Sagan described as nuclear winter
there's probability every year of this
happening we track asteroids bigger than
a certain size that are in deep from
space orbit orbits we luckily have this
giant vacuum cleaner that we put out in
space during the design phase of the
solar system called Jupiter that sucks
up a lot of stuff and if that doesn't
get you uh the uh the Moon is has its
face demonstrates how many near misses
we've had in almost any of the craters
you can see through a moderately sized
telescope uh would have done severe
damage to the Earth and and if not
extinct level itself although a couple
of them Copernicus crater ammonium uh
would pretty be pretty devastating the
impactor is just incredible especially
the angles that they would have come in
those are things I worry a lot about I
know uh my you know the guest I'll never
have on now since this podcast said
Harris this talked a lot about
bioterrorism
and that would involve you know
biological agents like viruses and
whatnot I'm not a biologist uh that
could cause you know just really imagine
if the case fatality rate imagine if it
was what it was but instead of killing
the elderly predominantly and that's a
tragedy but it killed children imagine
that um for the previous virus that
where I was with blobit that would be a
horrible thing I think we would have had
a very different reaction to it and not
to diminish the the deaths of the
elderly the million plus people that
died in the U.S by the way I do remember
again you know kind of the the sisteria
about how you know when uh when the
virus in its initial phases and in 2020
during the election you know the New
York Times have Trent on this front page
you know all hundred thousand Americans
that were considered to die of of covid
and I haven't seen an article about that
lately with the remaining 990
000 names have died since then why is
that and I think that will dovetail with
the final bullet point I'm worried about
could we have runaway
nanotechnological scenarios that either
through a coupling although this is kind
of forbidden in the question itself
which I don't consider AI but
nevertheless if there was some you know
kind of melding of nanotechnology where
you could connect to the physical world
from the digital world of AI where it
has some imperative to you know I mean
there's the paper clip you know kind of
parable of what happens I won't go
through that but if there were you know
kind of a a sentience that could connect
to the physical world now my friends
have a Tesla and as Michael Schumer has
pointed out you know he drives his Tesla
it has a lot of AI in it in fact Tesla's
is the most sophisticated you know
consumer grade AI like you can't buy a
chat GPT you can run on your computer
you can do whatever somehow has you know
tens of trillions of Nvidia gpus
somewhere you don't have that GPU set up
in your computer you have to pay for
access to it nevertheless uh the Tesla
has these dedicated chips these these
engines
um that power the AI on board and yet
now as Mike points out you know never
does my you know Tesla according to him
never does his Tesla you know decide
well it's actually faster to get to
Starbucks if I just you know drive down
the street you know and then plot out
all these these pedestrians to get to
Starbucks and get my latte
um so they're already like a connection
between a physical system an embodiment
of locomotion and animation the physical
wheels of the car driving the motor
somehow even with our primitive you know
what I think they call you know
generation three or whatever generation
four we're not even at what is accepted
by everybody Tesla calls what they had
full self driving it's beta whatever but
they don't they don't consider it like
level five or I forget what it is one of
you guys are correct so the point being
even in a level three or whatever it is
now things AIS or you know it's kind of
like giving your toddler a machine gun
um they're they're not at the level of
system now maybe you this machine gun is
not like I'm gonna do the damage and the
toddler's hands as it would be Putin's
hands or whoever your favorite bill is
zelensky I don't know everybody hates it
so the point is I'm not as worried about
that but when you do meld together the
uh the operating system with the
physical embodiment then things could
get interesting but it could get very
good it could be that we you know
imagine AI That's you know that's
actively participating in weather you
know in controlling the web which can be
done and is done in the Middle East for
example if they see clouds to produce
rain and a lot of the Gulf States
wouldn't exist in the you know very
opulent fashion that they do without
this kind of Technology now imagine you
have all these solar panels and then you
build them here in California and it's
freezing in May
snowing not too far from here uh you
know and they're covered up with snow
and well would it be great if you had
you know somebody to control the weather
based on forecasts based on some highly
complexified modeling uh the only you
know AI could maybe use to forecast and
then connecting it to the panels and the
grid itself that could be really good
and it could lead to an optimal you know
kind of behave so the question that
asked you know not to consider climate
change sorry well I do want to have on
I've tried to have on you know people
that you know like Lawrence Krauss and
and uh David Pogue and others that you
know are are more on the you know very
very concerned also on the left
politically speaking it'd be interesting
to have people you know that have an
alternative viewpoint I don't know this
guy Bjorn Lombard or whoever she's not
only a scientist but Steve coonan at NYU
is and I tried to get him on a very
haphazardly I'll try to get a mom again
he was a Provost at Caltech when I was a
postdoc there he's a brilliant guy he's
written a book you know I swear it much
much more sanguine about Humanity's
Prosper cool cat says to Michael not
sure Freeman Dyson will do interviews
that's true he can no longer do it
although with some AI avatars cruising
through the space at the speed of light
according to Michio Kaku and media Lobby
will I have an expert someone asks his
name is someone a hernia we have an
expert in the field of AI alignment I'm
not hearing good things about the
prospect of AI alignment prepared to
advancements in the capabilities of AI
so AI alignment I'm going to assume uh
for a lack of any real knowledge about
it has to do with you know kind of the
the
um you know the implications of AI to do
things and whether or not it has a CO
yeah you know vectorially aligned
pattern with what human humanity and the
flourishing of humanity would have so AI
alignment experts are those people again
I'm kind of assuming making this up you
know we're wondering whether or not
these these people consider the moral or
maybe the ethical
philosophical theological embodiments
you know one thing I've thought about as
someone who's Jewish and has a lot of
friends that are extremely you know
about practicing High practice about
these electricity on on the Sabbath on
Saturdays
so what will happen if we have some AI
chip you know that we download neural
link style into our brain and its power
and like are you allowed to to use it on
the Sabbath it's a question and then if
you're not and if you don't then will
that create you know multiple classes of
you know these these you know the
humanoids that are cybernetic interfaces
of you know man and machine but
nevertheless even without that you know
do these things have values what are
your obligations as a human to the Sim
to the AI itself if we really get to you
know Turing tests turn completeness AI
complete like can we turn it off can I
say that you know Bart you've been a bad
Bard or a bad chat bot you know it shuts
you down I know I wouldn't do that with
my bribot you know the the custom-made
Bop into Martian so I have had on Max
tegmark and Nick Bostrom who are the
most you know kind of some of the most
uh Pro uh you know renowned experts in
the implications of artificial
intelligence Max was on twice and the
guy's book is about being human in the
age of artificial intelligence live 3.0
and then of course Nick Bostrom wrote
about it and superintelligence and kind
of the ethics of the simulation
environment so I thought about that too
yes do we turn off a simulation can you
make it better by giving it the visceral
sense that led for example Einstein to
come up with the theory of general
relativity in the ninth time equivalence
principle yeah do you throw the computer
out the window and say this is free fall
do you blow it a capacitor every now and
then to teach you what pain feels like
if you're trying to simulate you know
hostage negotiation scenarios I don't
know these are these are very very
interesting questions okay I can do
without Sean Carroll says cool cat he's
interesting fail support is fellow
academics with regard to the book and
peer review system piss me off yeah Sean
and I don't see eye to eye and
everything no I mean uh either but he's
always interesting to talk to and you
know you may disagree about you know
again the thread of Donald Trump assumes
to come up all autologies academics but
uh but we often talk about things that I
do with Beth
um I could I want Elon to go super deep
on his urine dangers of this by the way
Sam Harris sends a video then uh Stephen
Devine says get the cronenon no you want
to yeah I do want to I've had them on
multiple times we did a debate on
Courage among those Channel
that was fun I'll have them on again
what popular Cosmic theories are to test
too big to test to create experiments
for
uh that's a great question we can't
actually create any Cosmic theories and
test them in the laboratory we can
replicate aspects you often hear this
physicists create the biggest explosion
since the Big Bay
um you know the Large Hadron Collide or
the Large Hadron Collider could make you
know black holes and
um they're very different it is true
that their temperature is equivalent to
the the 13 Tera electron bolt energy you
know Center of mass energy that the
Large Hadron Collider was recently
upgraded to
uh but that's pitifully small compared
to the you know 10 to the 16th GED
energies that the yearly Universe
featured if inflation took place so it
you know it's true it's at some time in
the early in year versus history it was
about as warm the entire universe was as
warm as this fire behind uh at some time
in the early University this is as warm
as the Sun but that doesn't mean that
you recreated the Universe um and so
it's difficult to think of doing an
experiment at all in cosmology where you
can actually have a you know random you
know control test or you could have a
variable that you have control over and
and one that you can leave unperturbed
so you can't actually do experiments
like you can in chemistry or biology
give a frog some kind of chemical and
see what happens to it and then you have
a control frog you don't do that too so
we can't really do experiments at all in
astronomy and certainly not in cosmology
where there might only be one here
astrology again asked does Academia need
to adopt more humility absolutely I'm
worried about Academia and the
um and the concern that we have really
Russ on you know whether or not we have
an appropriate attitude towards our
funding agencies and by that I don't
mean the National Science Foundation or
the or the department of energy I mean
you all I mean the public because we're
living in an age and I didn't get to my
my biggest fear which uh which has to do
with effectively the the ultimate
undermining and Trust in science
and maybe with that'll end I'm going to
ask one uh answer two more questions and
then I gotta dropped so that is that
when scientists exclude the general
public from what they're doing they do
something very dangerous but not just
dangerous for the public they do it it's
dangerous for them as well there's a
self-interest scientists do
communication about what we're doing to
the general public otherwise it's a huge
waste of time and what I'm worried about
is that so many of my colleagues think
that what they do is so far above
anything that I'm doing say at this
YouTube channel and I know that so my
colleagues are watching this right now
and saying well I usually back in the
laboratory maybe they're right but I
spent an awful lot of time in the lab
and mentoring students and traveling and
going to these telescopes and analyzing
data and this is kind of an outlet to me
that makes me a more well-rounded
scientist so
I think the more there should I should
have more competition there should be
many more like people like Andrew
huberman and I can't think of too many
people who really do this Sean Carroll
who does it um you know who's in these
are active faculty members know that are
scientists doing research Mr [__] is not
doing science really very much anymore
um I think he is technically still a
professor in New York City College and
then there yes Sean Carroll Andrew
huberman on the biology side
um you know Eric Weinstein who doesn't
do his podcast anymore although given
fox says he loves my conversations with
Eric the best thank you I enjoy them a
lot too especially now again in person
write down blanking on others that do it
and you know Brian Cox does stuff but
he's not really doing much in the way of
in theories and observations and stuff
also very people at The Cutting Edge and
that's what makes it so hard is that
through the authenticity you want the
scientists who's doing stuff in the
field you know on the classroom or in on
the computer or what have you you know
you have Jan 11 as a friend of the show
and friend of mine and she has her
Outreach Ally which is great called
Pioneer Works in real space in physical
space in Brooklyn and Red Hook you can
go visit it maybe I'll be there someday
so we need more of that and if we don't
I think science itself will be at risk
people will stop trusting us and that'll
be really bad for us and so I think
that's the biggest danger because once
science the science gets co-opted we've
seen this happen a lot in the last few
years a shutdown stem you know
protesting over George Floyd shut down
the journal's Nature and Science and
Academia and my experiments they were
shut down for a day and you know social
justice is not to be ignored and and so
forth on the other hand you have things
like Scientific American just publishes
complete nonsense though publishing you
know endorsing political candidates
again it's it's it only goes in One
Direction I'm waiting for just a one
scientific Outlet to just come out and
say that not only is Trump not a danger
uh but he's and I'm not saying I believe
this but it'll be really interesting I
mean shouldn't it be the case like if
he's so evil and so bad then why didn't
the world get destroyed and why didn't
had an autocracy come into play you know
you might say he's incompetent but he
can't be simultaneously a Machiavellian
villain and also incompetent right so
anyway
um science is at Great risk people don't
trust in science when you have people
not being able to make basic scientific
statements without fear of getting
cancer it's it's quite terrifying and if
we live in an anti-scientific age where
people don't believe in God and they
don't believe in science as a kid don't
know who to trust then I think it's game
over so Academia plays a huge role in
that because every serious scientist has
a PHD I know there are many scientists
who don't but whatever the ones that are
at R1 universities the teaching and the
research they all have phds what do you
know about a PhD he or she went to
college and they went to graduate school
um so Academia is is Upstream from these
impacts of signs on culture it's very
dangerous lots more questions there's
tens tens tens more questions I really
appreciate you all uh and and I
appreciate
statement Patrick's saying I watch all
the big YouTube scientists Brian does
some of the best interviews I always
come back to Brian for real information
thank you so much Poindexter I believe
more than ever you're committed to
Scientific Integrity is genuine I love
your Mantra always be curious ABC that
is
your questions are the best part of the
interview is congrats on 100K the
question is the answer wow that is cool
into oh intangible says you are my
favorite science Communicator just by a
variety of quality guests you engage and
they break down action topics thank you
so much 111 subscriber 1000 subscribers
congrats all around Brian Keating is
kind of looking like Buzz Lightyear
Mike Rose love that yeah I got the buzz
buzz cut kind of went in and said give
me the Andrew huberman slash Lex
Friedman and then he says to infinity
and beyond 200k well let's make a date
for that let's let's make a date for
even before 100 200k let's make a date
and 150 000. I will see you then answer
more of your questions please send them
to me I love the questions and concerns
me anytime there's even a way you can
leave a voice message on my website by
keaton.com sign up for the newsletter
because that's the only thing that I
have complete control over I can send
you guys things links to my books free
giveaways samples meteorites ebooks
audiobooks All Those Questions okay uh
love you guys all so much thank you for
allowing me to have this platform and I
hope you know I will never take it for
Brantley and I'll continue to have on
controversial people like I said Jordan
Peterson uh is coming on the show I'll
always ask your opinion doesn't mean
I'll I'll you know respect what you say
because I have my own free volition but
um but I want you to know how much your
support really means to to me and uh and
then how much I rely on you to keep the
child belt so please share it okay love
you all so much and I thank you all so
much take care see you at 150 Jeff
[Music]